I wish I had better news to start with
today but I don't the FCC is going to
repeal net neutrality not soon not in
early 2018 not later this month but it
appears that it's going to happen today
it might have already happened by the
time you listen to today's show or watch
today's episode and this is going to
allow a lot of really bad things to
happen including allowing internet
service providers to speed up service to
some websites of their choosing or
platforms as well to slow down or
outright block access to other web sites
or services how despicable is it that
something that Republicans and Trump
will call a major win in reversing Obama
era legislation will actually be
terrible for consumers this applies to
consumers of media and users of the
Internet in other words basically
everybody 83% of Americans oppose this
plan I'd argue that some of the 17% that
doesn't oppose it doesn't fully
understand the implications of what's
going on right the people who actually
understand what's going on with net
neutrality and what it is and still want
to repeal it must be way smaller than
the 17 percent roughly that polls point
to and what's important to understand is
that the Republican establishment was
not always opposed to net neutrality
there are some Republican voters who are
jumping on the bandwagon they've
basically fallen prey to the talking
points of the cable lobbying industry
and they believe that it's actually a
good thing to repeal net neutrality and
it's become very partisan but if you go
back to the 2015 net neutrality rules
that were passed during the Obama
administration the precursor to that
package was actually from the Republican
George W Bush FCC under george w bush
the FCC created some sort of general
guiding principles that led to what was
passed under president obama and those
are the rules that now the Trump
administration the Trump FCC is looking
to repeal the FCC chairman at the time
was Michael Powell the son of colon
Powell a
publican chairman of the FCC and he
actually said in a speech that Internet
users should have four freedoms and that
includes exactly the type of freedoms
that there's at least an attempt made by
President Obama's net neutrality rules
to provide and again that was a
Republican FCC Chairman so this is a
significant move to the right and the
backstory of what is apparently going to
end today in a way anyway one chapter
might end today is this depressing
conversation we had last week with
attorney Andrew Torres who said bottom
line this is going to be repealed and it
becomes more a question of how will we
react to this repeal of net neutrality
to maybe try to restore some of the
principles there are actually a few
Republicans in Congress coming out in
support of net neutrality yet oh now
but it's largely just lyft service at
this point it's all to appeal to their
constituents who by and large are in
favor of keeping that neutrality of
course the FCC will have the vote it
will be three or two and they'll gut it
but maybe there's some hope for the
future with them well I guess let's try
to find some upside right one hope I
have is that more cities and towns will
look seriously at municipal broadband
right public internet options is a
really interesting case from a really
small I don't know if I can even call it
a town it's kind of a village in western
Massachusetts called Leverett or shoots
berry now I don't remember which it is
that established municipal broadband of
course it's much easier to do in a small
municipality than it is in a city so
that's one possibility hopefully it will
also accelerate the projects by private
industry to bring free internet to
everyone Elon Musk has ideas Facebook
has ideas and I get it these are major
corporations with financial interests in
doing lists or not just doing it out of
charity but I would argue that free
internet for all outside of the internet
service provider cable lobbying
industrial complex is a good thing
because repealing net neutrality if we
had real competition for Internet
service wouldn't be as bad but what
we're doing and what may have already
been happened by the time you hear this
is that we're repealing net neutrality
and yet most people have one option from
who they can buy in
internet from that they can buy internet
from where they live that's a disastrous
combination and I don't believe for a
second that none of the Internet service
providers are going to do the things
that they legally be allowed to do once
net neutrality is repealed we hear from
these companies these Internet service
providers we would never do internet
fast lines we would never start charging
people more if they want to access
independent media or Netflix or whatever
the case is just look at Portugal
Portugal had what we sort of can call
net neutrality type legislation they
repealed it and it's been a disaster now
in Portugal Pat you've got like your
basic internet fee and then if you want
to use messaging type apps you pay extra
that includes Skype if you want to use
social apps you by the social tier we
joke that that's what it's going to
become it's happened in Portugal yeah
that's a disaster we don't want it but
also are you surprised that we're not
seeing independent websites coming out
in support of keeping that neutrality
like for today maybe just shutting down
Google and oh yeah yeah and Amazon and
protests perhaps we've seen it we're not
seeing it today you're right but we did
see those types of protests we're
blacking out our site to defend net
neutrality or whatever did I mean it the
proof is in the pudding in the sense
that they did it and we're still getting
a repeal today so this is the reality
this is what will happen prepare for it
unless we vote them out soon enough to
get this this repeal cancelled so to
speak it could get really really bad and
we've been covering it I know that
corporate media has not really been
talking very much about net neutrality
it doesn't really serve the political
aim no and goals no incentive whatsoever
we've been talking about it but sadly
it's still going to happen the video you
just finished watching was made possible
by you through the membership program
you can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership